airline mit fernweh werden präsentiert
von swiss ein gästehaus auf der insel
bali patricia und romano tschudi wollen
aus dem alltag ausbrechen
familie folglich sie sucht ihr glück in
kanada in den rocky mountains bauen sie
ein holzfäller unternehmen auf tobias
bayer und michael paris und in englisch
etwas eigenes eine kleine bar aufwarte
wind oder
[Musik]
weit und breit kein gast in sicht auf
bali warten studis immer noch auf zu
kommen wo das haus haben romano und
patricia überteuert gemietet zudem ist
es in einem schlechteren zustand als
gedacht
[Musik]
schwimm regen wir uns der traum vom
erste haus in den tropen droht zu
platzen
[Musik]
zenit wie kalzium reinvestiert an die
hoffnung dass das wirklich der luft oder
wasser strömen für unterzeichnete man es
richtig macht und jetzt ist meadows
hätte im prinzip - und in der letzten
folge versuchten dies alles mögliche um
urlauber in ihr gästehaus zu locken aber
fremd der findet sogar eine balinesische
opferzeremonie auf wird der ventura
mussten tobias und michael den
handwerkern genau auf die finger schauen
die halterung für die kuka ist nicht in
der mitte und sie machten druck auf ihre
neuen bauführer sylvari um die eröffnung
rückt näher
wir haben noch viel viel arbeit
schulanfang in kanada june musste sich
zurechtfinden ohne ein wort englisch
der erste auftrag für christian aber
seine maschinen steckten beim zoll fest
[Musik]
sechs uhr morgens minus 25 grad
ein ganz normaler wintertag in kanada
nicht ganz denn endlich sind alle
maschinen dar und christian volk kann
loslegen
die kolosse mussten einige hürden nehmen
bis sie ankam
zuletzt hatte sie der zoll wegen solchen
gefahr festgehalten
an den roten bändern klebten noch rechte
von schweizer erde gemacht und die logen
und das holz bauen und unterdrückten
produktiv machen aber finanziell
natürlich sehr wichtig sie das kleine
modell der und er ist da wo wir
eigentlich sie zwei oder verträumt oder
[Musik]
zu hause in vier worte beginnt auch fürs
und schon und ehefrau simone der tag
schon besucht seit vier monaten in der
neuen heimat die vorschulklasse
[Musik]
mittlerweile gott dass er gern am anfang
war es schwierig da hat dann die welle
die erste zwei wochen daheim ein drama
aber das ist ein schwieriger hat kein
wort verstanden und er hat noch nicht
wisst wie alles läuft aber jetzt
mittlerweile mittlerweile gern tägliches
ritual im winter die schlittenfahrt zum
bus
der schulbus hält an der einfahrt zu
ihrem grundstück bis dahin ist es ein
kilometer
[Musik]
und jackson ist das neue
familienmitglied
er soll auf simone und schon aufpassen
volksleben mitten im wald unter gibt es
bären die futtersuche john hat eine
lange fahrt vor sich volks wohnen rund
45 minuten von der schule entfernt
[Musik]
da
das gästehaus von romano und patricia
steht leer
750 franken kostet sie das jeden monat
und hausmeister neo man arbeitet auch
nicht gratis
seit wochen versuchen sie den vermieter
davon zu überzeugen die pacht zu senken
trafen uns mit bitte frauenclique weil
ich es für uns ganz sicher und region
was süßes horst etc
es ist einfach viel zu viel aber das
wenige was sie sind und der vertrag nur
bis im september gemacht haben verlieren
nicht allzu viel geld also wenn nicht
bald was passiert ist es vorbei mit dem
gästehaus aber so schnell geben die
puhdys nicht auf
sie waren zu schreiner wiktorin u boot
mittlerweile kennen sie ihm gut er hat
die möbel für ihr gästehaus gezimmert
wir würden gerne fotos machen ist das
okay und die größe müssen ja klar den
kunden bilden das mögen ihre neue idee
möbel und kunsthandwerk bis bali in der
schweiz zu verkaufen
bei uns in zeiten gegangen ist eine
sonntag noch mal probiert und wenn wir
jetzt mal funktionieren
das fängt ja na ja da hätte sich ständig
passt
von gästehaus betreibern zu händlern
studis erfinden sich neu demnächst
fliegen sie zurück in die schweiz
[Musik]
michael paris und sein lebensgefährte
tobias beier haben nur noch wenig zeit
bis zur eröffnung ihrer bar im
einkaufszentrum hält campana rio
hier kommen die drei bilder ok alle drei
eine auf einer linie
wir bestimmen gleich wie hoch
es fehlt nicht mehr viel bis alles
perfekt ist
die eigene bar im sonnigen süden davon
träumen die beiden schon seit zwölf
jahren seit sie ein paar sind
gehört mir vorstellen sie sind die augen
auf morgen
deshalb ist da
am tag sie und blieb michael kümmert
sich um stars und den feinschliff in ton
hat der herren kleidung verkauft hier
ist er jetzt der chef hinter dem tresen
[Musik]
tobias war ground service agent am
flugplatz in bern belpmoos für mich ist
das gut
könnten sie das eine noch etwas drehen
sie das herzstück tausende kleiner
spiegel
die sco bremer in der wahlheimat ist
sammelt und wegen welt
aber passt dieser soll das spiel
bürgerlichkeit und mit farbiger fordern
es ist fantastisch dass er ganz cool
jetzt können die beiden endlich die bar
bestücken und einräumen
[Musik]
im kanadischen clearwater hat sich
simone mit einem heizstrahler an ihren
schreibtisch verzogen
wenn schon in der schule ist hat sie
zeit für büroarbeit wie schon in der
schweiz kümmert sich die 38-jährige um
die buchhaltung der firma bis christian
abends wieder kommt ist sie alleine
also blieb denn bliebe ich nicht die dem
land denn dann wird sich wieder heim
besser sind darunter
hier werden die geheimen
[Musik]
simone hatte im zürcher weinland ihre
familie und die freunde in der umgebung
hier gibt es nur hund jackson
[Musik]
draußen im wald hat ihr mann christian
seinen werkstatt container aufgebaut
die teuren holzernte maschinen müssen
ständig gewartet werden
christian ist nicht nur post unternehmer
sondern auch gelernter mechaniker für
sie machen
sechs monaten noch mit der familie sieht
vielmehr vermisse ich meine familie aber
überlege die als bearish das viel
extremer hitze kann muss es wirklich
bedeutet und sicher bedeutet im herbst
stehen
ich habe nochmal klaus stöber reden aber
irgendwie war sega volks haben ihr
gesamtes vermögen in das neue leben in
kanada investieren
es gibt kein zurück
[Musik]
für zwei wochen sind romano und patricia
in der alten heimat den vertrag für das
wohnhaus am bodensee haben sie
vorsorglich noch nicht gekündigt sie
vermieten es wochenweise an urlauber im
gegensatz zu baden
sind sie hier gut gebucht
warst du
moody's starten plan b sie haben einen
koffer voller dekorationsartikel aus
bari mitgebracht
per e-mail hat patricia verschiedene
läden in der umgebung kontaktiert
[Musik]
who chefin für welche produkte das
interesse bestimmt wenn sie ganz toll
war
wenn sie bis heute stellen wir benennen
dank kommt ja vom tiergarten rettung
ja noch nie so speziell
in einem laden für geschenkartikel in
amriswil haben sie einen termin bekommen
moody's präsentieren zum ersten mal ihr
sortiment
[Musik]
auf fuerteventura gibt es ein
unerwartetes problem
tobias muss dringend zum zahnarzt seit
tagen schon planen in starke
zahnschmerzen
jetzt kann er den arztbesuch nicht
weiter aufschieben
das ist das eigentlich fertig haben
tobias hat angst vor einer infektion
zum glück hat er einen zahnarzt gefunden
der kurzfristig noch einen termin frei
hatte
es ist schon ein paar mal gemacht und
die sache darum glaubt hab jetzt schon
wurzel behandelt ich glaube schon einmal
doch wieder gehalten
[Musik]
dr scharping lebt schon seit 26 jahren
hier keine kohle mehr drauf nichts
werden mittel durch den sollte man also
ausmachen
[Musik]
in amriswil im kanton thurgau zeigen
studis ihre objekte also privat oder ich
liebe genauso holz hund in der regel und
sie aber und verarbeitet wird es noch
auf bali
es ist aber so dass ich mir sage ich
jetzt mal eine idee hat wo möchte jetzt
namen genannt reporterin an das design
bekommen denen einfach gemacht da sein
denn speziell
die ladenbesitzerin wollen darüber
nachdenken ob die enten in ihr angebot
passen
der spruch für mich gut verlaufen sind
trasse für große produkt- und
[Musik]
dank wenn wir da jetzt service point of
view den krieg um abstellungen zu hause
in kesswil checkt patricia die buchungen
für bali
also ich jetzt sie dürfen ihre zimmer
nur als privatunterkunft inserieren für
professionelle buchungsplattformen fehlt
ihnen immer noch eine lizenz die lizenz
haben sie beantragt aber noch nicht
bekommen
zwei anfragen
immerhin ist das gästehaus auf bali
nimmt scheinbar fahrt auf
[Musik]
in kanada läuft das geschäft wie
geschmiert
[Musik]
für ein sägewerk fällen christian und
seine männer bis zu 1000 bäume pro tag
eine seilwinde schütz die tonnenschweren
kolosse davor im steilgelände
abzurutschen
die spezielle binde ist christians
erfolgsrezept das erste produkt am ende
dafür gerade da wo wir sie brauchen
unter zur maschine wir sind so viel holz
oder stein und das ich dass ich zur kur
vor dem herd große zeit einiges haben
wir etwas mehr erwartet
[Musik]
[Applaus]
in clearwater holt simone ihren sohn von
der schule ab wie fast jeden nachmittag
[Musik]
wie alt ist er ist leighton wochen
ich kann welten muss widerstehen süß
[Musik]
den ganzen schule
da müssen wir daheim nachher trockene
anziehen
[Musik]
sechs stunden dauert der unterricht in
der vorschulklasse jeden tag
eigentlich könnte schon den schulbus
nehmen so wie seine mitschüler es für
ihn will da nicht einfach eine stunde
früher daheim bevor der letzte bus stieg
dann wäre irgendwie um eine vom tag und
macht auch wenn vermieter kann mich noch
ein bisschen mitreden mit anderen eltern
und kompromisslose trifft einfach nicht
wirklich viel übt und hätte nicht
sowieso groß fester oder so romand
trifft es ist eigentlich schwieriger wie
dass es mir vorgestellt habe zwar immer
noch schnell bei briefkasten halten
wie schon lange keine briefe mehr geholt
haben vielleicht hat es ja mal wieder
weil hier drin
was störte verschlüsse macht anders
ach ja der andere stimme ja auch männer
guck mal gar nichts gar nichts du immer
wieder
[Musik]
fuße der scharfmacher aldingen im
baselbiet mutter rosmarie hat für
tochter patricia und schwiegersohn
romano 1 morger zubereitet natürlich
gibt das gästehaus auf bali zu reden
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
aber immerhin haben wir jetzt mal heim
und setzt und träumen darf
meine tochter soll wasser und auch
tochter natascha kommt vorbei sie hat
sich extra freigenommen
sie will ihre eltern wenn sie in der
schweiz sind so oft wie möglich sehen
[Musik]
ja
fast vier monate konnte patricia ihre
tochter nicht in die arme schließen
eine lange zeit für beide dass sie
einfach so wenn skype und sich
unterhalten aber nicht einfach den tod
und das macht mir schon mit schaffen und
obwohl er grüßt vorhatte
aber so schön danke besonders wenn es
denn wirklich gespürt
sr studer
fr
[Musik]
auf wird der ventura sind es nur noch
wenige stunden bis zur einweihungsparty
gut ein dutzend einladungen haben
michael und tobias an bekannte und
geschäftspartner verteilt arbeiten
welche mit eingaben haben aber schon
einen parkenden kommen
tobias konnte die operation aufschieben
um den zahn steht es nicht so schlimm
wie befürchtet
30 lilien haben sie extra für diesen tag
bestellt 55
ein drittel der bar ist für michaels
boutique reserviert sie wollen nicht nur
cocktails servieren sondern auch
souvenirs verkaufen
fürs erste sind das badesalz mützen und
t shirts für frauen auch das was für
kinder
und wenn nicht läuft dann haben wir ganz
lange zeit die shirts und trikots zum
tragen
sie sind fast fertig aber dass bio unter
zapfhahn fehlen noch
[Musik]
die biermann
die kollektion mit ihrem logo hat
michael entworfen
später will er das angebot mit weiteren
accessoires ergänzen
sein
der lieferant von der brauerei endlich
die einfache zapfanlage passt gut in das
knappe gut schede auswanderer und kann
leicht überall montiert werden
ok ungefähr da hier da oder dort
vielleicht doch nicht was rüber
das gibt mir verschleppt
und es soll noch die kleine stühle rhein
nicht raus und dann wisst ihr wir gehen
mit viel licht wie schön es hier ist
kein problem hier zu lassen jetzt sich
nur noch in schale werfen dann sind
tobias und michael bereit
wochenende in clearwater volkes genießen
den kanadischen lifestyle vor ein paar
tagen hat christian den motorschlitten
getestet mit umwerfenden erfolg bei
einer rasanten fahrt ist die lenkstange
gebrochen
ich rege die gesteckt und mit republik
gelagert und dann nicht weshalb wieso
das hantieren und kläre wurde ganz
algerien mit vollgas in den bau mir noch
eine chance gegen 7.40 hatten moniert
weil wir nur noch schnee und regen und
motorradrocker es macht spaß
eine reparatur in einer fachwerkstatt
lohnt sich nicht mehr
da ich jetzt mal kanadisch klickt
juni bis zum 30
[Gelächter]
auf geht's zur jubelfahrt
[Musik]
damals geld doch mal musik rot-gelbe
wichtig das recht weiß wie das läuft wo
lärm und rauch richtig kraft
[Musik]
zurück unter palmen patricia und romano
konnten ihre zimmer vermieten
das gästehaus ist ausgebucht bitte
dieses zimmer vorbereiten
bei den anderen beiden nur das bett das
letzte freie zimmer ist für einen gast
aus deutschland reserviert gegen europa
denn dazu das thema fahrrad machen
afghanistan vorbereitet wenn sie nicht
warum sich peter viel schöneren sein mut
macht
wir haben ein kurzer moment wirklich mir
gar und eine umgestaltung von contex gut
ist und er hätte sich nie getraut sagen
aber ich habe sich das ist nicht gut und
kommt zu guten dann nein nicht wie
üblich erst noch gemacht und damals auch
okay
sarah wurde von einem fahrer pünktlich
vom flughafen denpasar abgeholt sie
wohnt 14 tage bei studis aber schnell
wieder vom flughafen hierher
normalerweise so dann würde ich sagen
zuerst mal das zimmer zeigt das erste
mal auf bali premiere alles freuen
[Musik]
sie hat früher für spanische
verhältnisse der rote teppich für die
partygäste auf werte ventura ist bereit
bis nach böhmen und nachher die gleichen
sind
teppich ist da
ich nehme das sogar mit mist doch klein
[Musik]
seit wochen haben sie auf diesen tag
hingearbeitet
[Musik]
pünktlich auf die minute öffnen sie die
türen zu stars fuerteventura
aber ich weiß nicht wie das geht alles
ist fertig und das budget aufgebraucht
ist ein mit oder ohne beide seiten sonst
das heißt so vielleicht rollt das auto
oder jemand stolpert
da haben wir schon der erste
versicherungsfall
ab jetzt müssen sie geld verdienen
kurz ein bisschen ziehen ja ich gott
raum ambiente raumduft was er bringen
schneller erschlossen
so knie
[Musik]
hat sich die band jung für das habe ich
fast vergessen die seite irgendwo die
verstreuten münchen sollen glück bringen
eine gepflogenheit die michael aus
ungarn mitgebracht hat kurz nach
eröffnung sind noch keine gäste da
aber tobias und michael haben offenbar
bereits gelernt zu warten
ja in der letzten folge müssen sich die
beiden als barkeeper zum ersten mal
gönnen sie sich einen freien tag für
eine partitur
[Musik]
in kanada genießt familie volk die neue
freiheit dabovic mache kaschmir wilhelm
busch gar nichts und mitarbeiter mirco
legt sein meisterstück ab
auf bali könnte für studis der plan mit
dem gästehaus aufgehen doch patricia
trifft eine folgenschwere entscheidung
[Musik]
airline voll mit fernweh ich habe er mit
hey wir sind präsentiert wurde